la facture pétrolière française sera en
1980 a largement supérieur à 100
milliards de francs voilà ce que vient
de déclarer monsieur André Giraud
ministre de l'Industrie après l'annonce
des hausses du prix du baril décidé par
les pays producteurs le pétrole
aujourd'hui plus qu'hier encore il faut
donc chercher d'autres sources
énergétiques que le pétrole que le
pétrole beaucoup pense que notre
fréquente espoir réside dans le pétrole
vert un rêve utopiste c'est à vous de
juger après avoir suivi ce reportage de
Jean-Charles Deniaud
Cornu alambic les idées vont bon train
pour essayer de remplacer l'essence par
un autre carburant en voici une
originale bien qu'elle soit connue
depuis fort longtemps le topinambou
transformé en alcool ce légume est un
bon carburant ce n'est pas une
plaisanterie ouvrons d'abord le
dictionnaire au mot topinambour
tubercule de la famille des composés
c'est un légume rustique qui ne gèle pas
ne craint pas la sécheresse et pousse
jusqu'à 1500 mètres d'altitude enfin
avantage important il se cultive dans
presque tous les sols des plus argileux
au plus léger depuis la fin de la guerre
la culture du topinambour a été
abandonnée faire pousser quelques
tubercule dans un carré de jardin c'est
bien mais est-ce possible de cultiver le
topinambour d'une façon industrielle
du topinambour ne peut être envisagée de
manière industrielle
qu'à partir de l'instant ou on aura
réussi à en semer de même manière que
l'on pratique avec des pommes de terre
c'est à dire avec un espacement entre
les rayons de 80 cm et avec un
espacement de 60 cm entre chaque pied
sur le rayon et fait un essai de récolte
mécanique est-ce que c'est une culture
qui revient cher c'est une culture qui
reviendrait très peu cher puisqu'il n'y
aurait pratiquement que très peu
d'engrais et le prix de revient de
l'achat du plan de tubercule
et l'amortissement du matériel de
récolte la plante ne nécessite aucun
soin pendant la croissance c'est à dire
simplement un butage pour permettre aux
tubercule de se développer en surface et
bien c'est très simple à partir de ce
topinambour on va le râper et on va
obtenir ce produit
ce produit va on va le laisser
faire monter pendant un mois environ et
ensuite il est prêt à la distillation
alors c'est ce que vous avez dans la
Cornu ici c'est du jus de topinambour la
distillation se fait dans une colonne
avec refroidisseur ici et on obtient là
de l'alcool pur de topinambour avec 50
tonnes à l'hectare combien de d'alcool
de topinambour pouvez-vous produire
alors avec 50 tonnes de hectares on peut
produire un dixième c'est à dire environ
4 à 5000 litres d'alcool pur sans aucune
autre transformation après la sortie de
l'alambic l'alcool pur et versé dans le
réservoir de la voiture
monsieur ce moteur est-il normal oui
c'est un moteur de série c'est très
normal alors comment le transformez-vous
pour le faire fonctionner à l'alcool de
topinambour
d'abord il faut modifier
modifier les réglages du carbuérateur
c'est-à-dire changer les giteurs
d'alimentation et puis installer un
réservoir à l'alcool avec un système de
robinet pour passer de l'essence à
l'alcool c'est une transformation qui
revient cher non c'est insignifiant il y
a eu des robinets des tuyaux et puis les
gicleurs la voiture fonctionne comme
avec l'essence à quelle vitesse
voulez-vous je roule pratiquement aussi
vite qu'avec les sommes et au point de
vue consommation la consommation est
sensiblement la même et la voiture elle
a les mêmes reprises a le même dynamisme
ça marche ça marche pas mal
effectivement ça marche pas mal la
voiture démarre bien elle roule tout à
fait normalement sans à coup
en plus notons qu'elle ne pollue pas
puisqu'elle ne rejette dans l'air que de
la vapeur d'eau
[Musique]
quelles sont les possibilités du
topinambour bah écoutez en gros un
hectare de topinambour fait actuellement
40 tonnes c'est 40 tonnes donnent
3600 à 4000 litres d'alcool pur et ce
qui fait que nous pourrions arriver avec
un million d'hectares cultivés en France
à intervenir d'une façon très très
importante dans l'économie et vous
pensez que c'est possible je pense que
dès l'année prochaine si les pouvoirs
publics donnent le feu vert nous serons
déjà nous interviendrons d'une façon
heureuse sur ce terrain-là et que d'ici
1982 nous pouvons être
certainement assurer la moitié de la
consommation d'essence de carburant en
France et je puis vous dire que depuis
quelques jours je suis à Paris où je
bien je t'ai reçu hier à l'hôtel
Matignon je suis actuellement et je
repars tout à l'heure rencontrer les
responsables des différents ministères
techniques et je crois pouvoir dire que
ils prennent le dossier est très très au
sérieux et les pétroliers
les pétroliers et
pétrolier et chacun son temps
alors l'alcool de topinambour c'est pas
de la fumée
d'embour est une réalité et je pense que
elle sera une une forme de de
renaissance de l'économie française
après la fermentation du fumier qui
dégage du méthane après le compost
l'alcool de betterave ou de vin le
topinambour entre donc dans la nouvelle
famille du pétrole agricole du pétrole
vert un espoir peut-être pour les années
à venir
[Musique]